der satellit lisa pathfinder hat den
höchsten ort der menschheit im all
geschaffen jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction auf der suche nach
gravitationswellen im all konnte der
rückstand der menschheit geschaffen
werden
aber erst mal alles auf anfang der
satellit der esa mit dem namen lisa
pathfinder ist mit großen erwartungen
ins all gestartet die raumsonde hat zwei
gold- platin- würfel an bord mit diesem
wird eine technik getestet die dann in
einem aus drei satelliten bestehenden
riesigen systemen namens leiser
angewendet werden sollen der staat dafür
ist für das jahr 2034 geplant in lisa
pathfinder bis hin befinden sich frei
schwebende würfel rund 35 zentimeter
voneinander entfernt diese entfernung
wird ständig per laser kontrolliert wenn
eine gravitationswellen dann auf die
würfel trifft können die leser direkt
messen wie sich der abstand der würfel
zueinander verändert allerdings ist der
abstand der würfel im satelliten so
gering dass mit diesem test satelliten
keine gravitationswellen gefunden werden
könnte der ort für diese messung wird l1
sein einen lagrange punkt das ist ein
punkt hier zwischen sonne und erde an
dem nahezu absolute schwerelosigkeit
herrscht da sich dort die gravitation
von erde und sonne aufheben
gravitationswellen sind dort also der
einzige faktor der einfluss auf die lage
der würfel hat in leiser wird die
technik dann mit einer entfernung der
satelliten von einer million kilometern
voneinander angewendet bei dieser
entfernung ist dann die
wahrscheinlichkeit gravitationswellen
wieder via satellit zu entdecken viel
höher als mit jeder anderen messmethode
hier auf der erde und nicht im all
wurden die gravitationswellen ja schon
gefunden im laser interferometer ja wie
techno rave up side story einfach kurz
lego wurden sie in den usa nachgewiesen
das prinzip bei leiser und allen anderen
gravitationswellen detektoren ist immer
das gleiche wenn die gravitationswellen
wie ein stein im wasser wellen auslösen
und so die raumzeit krümmel werden sie
auch die bahn von nicht verändern nicht
klappt ja eine unveränderliche
geschwindigkeit von 299 millionen 792
1458 meter pro sekunde wenn aber eine
gravitationswellen einen lichtstrahl
durchkreuzt muss er
verändern da ja die raumzeit gekrümmt
wird und damit auch die zeit verändert
wird ein lichtstrahl würde vermeintlich
seine laufzeit verändern bzw eine andere
distanz durchlaufen um das zu messen
wird in den gravitationswellen
detektoren einem interferometer ein
laserstrahl in zwei lichtstrahlen auf
zwei strecken recht wegen dich
zueinander aufgeteilt und wieder
zurückgeworfen beide strahlen sollen die
gleiche zeit für die strecke benötigen
beim lego sind das 24 kilometer lange
röhren gelingt es den forschern im all
gravitationswellen direkt nachzuweisen
ist das ein mit in denen in lego
entdeckten kavitation sven
vergleichbarer sensationeller erfolg vor
allem erhofft man sich dort viel öfter
gravitationswellen zu finden da der
abstand der satelliten so so so viel
größer sein wird als beim lego die
ersten schritte zu einem solchen erfolg
haben die forscher nun hinter sich
gebracht seit dem ersten märz 2016
laufen die messungen im lisa pathfinder
auf hochtouren und sind sehr erfolgreich
zitat die messung des ersten laser
interferometer sind alle sind viel
besser als wir erwartet hatten
wir können den abstand der beiden frei
fallenden test massen genauer als den
durchmesser eines einzelnen atoms
bestimmen so gerd heinze vom max planck
institut für gravitationsphysik diese
messgenauigkeit ist dem all wirklich ein
marion sogar fünfmal so hoch wie
erwartet
mit leiser pathfinder habe man dem
direktor vom max planck institut für
gravitationsphysik gas landsmann zufolge
außerdem den höchsten ort geschaffen den
die menschheit kennt das man spricht
zudem auch noch die pläne und
erwartungen für die zukunft des
projektes an zitat mit der von leiser
paar feinde erreichten messgenauigkeit
könnte ein weltraumobservatorium wie
liza die gravitationswellen vom
verschmelzenden extrem massereichen
schwarzen löchern in galaxien im
gesamten universum nachweisen
zitat ende das wäre wirklich ein
sensationeller erfolg wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann lass mir gerne
einen daumen nach oben da und natürlich
ein kostenloses abo und schreibt ihre
einschätzung zur der forschung in die
kommentare halte das für einen großen
erfolg oder sagt er
jetzt wo wir die gravitationswellen
schon gefunden haben
und sich der aufwand doch gar nicht mehr
lasst es mich in den kommentaren wissen
und bis dann bleibt dran